good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson time thank you kevin it's friday
mostly because it's not thursday
yesterday was thursday a day that will
live in shame in the history of the
american news business yesterday last
night
every news network in this country but
this one faithfully surrendered its
entire prime time lineup to nancy pelosi
so in place of news coverage people who
tuned in got two straight hours of
unedited campaign propaganda scripted by
the democratic party
the effect was north korean every
channel the same nothing like it has
ever happened in this country now the
news anchors who faithfully did pelosi's
bidding pretended they were airing some
sort of congressional hearing
but they were lying it was not a hearing
at a hearing dissent is permitted the
other side can speak
evidence is presented evidence is not
censored or deceptively edited that's
not allowed
so what we saw last night was definitely
not a hearing it was a show trial there
was no pretense of fairness or accuracy
the whole thing was indecent
how many people were convinced by what
they saw last night hmm right around
zero
they're not going to win a single vote
so why'd they do it there had to be a
reason they're not that stupid
well the reason they did it is every
minute news anchors are whining about
some imaginary threat from q anon
remember q and on every minute they're
doing that they're not covering the
collapse of the american economy
something everyone actually cares about
collapse is a strong word but
how would you describe it today
inflation hit 8.6 those the official
numbers those the numbers arrived at
using the government's own cooked
metrics but it's still the highest
increase in inflation in more than 40
years so it's not surprising the
consumer confidence is at the lowest
level ever recorded why really it comes
down to energy
the cost of energy is up nearly 40
percent over last year
the average price of a gallon of gas is
now over five bucks but it won't stop
there jp morgan predicts it'll get to
six dollars and soon
so when the price of fuel goes up so
does the price of everything else
because our transportation systems are
dependent on the price of fuel and when
it gets high enough people can't go
anywhere
even the police
in michigan one department says it can
no longer respond to emergency calls
because the price of gas has gone too
high quote we've exhausted what funds
were budgeted for fuel with several
months to go before the budget reset
said the sheriff of isabella county on
tuesday quote i've instructed the
deputies to attempt to manage whatever
calls are acceptable over the phone
so enforcing the law over the phone
it sounds like a story from the third
world but that's america it's michigan
and it's just the beginning
a cnbc survey just found that 68 of
corporate cfos are predicting a
recession soon
zero chief financial officers surveyed
by cnbc believed a recession could be
avoided all of them thought it was
absolutely inevitable
what are the effects well one of them is
staples food prices they were already up
five percent in december they're now up
more than 10 year-over-year
so when food becomes too expensive to
buy you have a crisis how is the
administration responding to this crisis
a demonstrable crisis well biden has
just unveiled new regulations on ethanol
by the way here's a really simple test
if you want to know you're speaking to
someone who understands anything about
science or the environment anyone who
tells you ethanol is good for the quote
environment is either ignorant or lying
we know after decades of studying it
that ethanol hurts the environment there
is no environmental benefit to ethanol
and there's a massive cost both to the
land
and also to you
thanks to biden gasoline refiners will
be forced to blend 20 billion gallons of
ethanol because it's a renewable fuel
for the planet
but what this really is is a requirement
from the biden administration to burn
food in your car
that's what ethanol is
it's corn
so what happens when you divert food
crops like corn to ethanol production
well we know the answer because it's
been studied four decades in 2008 an
evolutionary biologist at cornell called
david pimental wrote this quote the use
of corn for ethanol has led to major
increases in the price of u.s beef
chicken pork
eggs bread cereal milk
it's a boon to agribusiness and it bane
to consumers in fact the director
general of the un food and agriculture
organization reports that using 22
pounds of corn to produce one gallon of
ethanol is already causing food
shortages
well of course that was 2008. this is
not news anyone who's been paying
attention can tell you ethanol is bad
for the environment it's terrible for
engines
and it is above all a disaster for your
food supply so at the same moment we are
facing food shortages the bite
administration has decided to make food
scarcer and more expensive
food will be just as expensive as
gasoline you probably hadn't heard about
that because once again last night every
single news network in this country
except ours was reporting on something
else here are their priorities
this prime time presentation was both
clear and it was compelling the first in
a historic set of hearings here this is
not just about what happened on january
6 or in the days leading up to it it's
about a clear and present danger to our
democracy i have to say it's just
historic to me
this was a hearing unlike any other i
think the committee did a great job
tonight i thought liz cheney was
particularly strong it was a a very
powerful very well produced if you will
two-hour presentation tonight the
january 6 committee concluded the first
of a series of its public hearings and
the point was abundantly clear our
democracy remains in danger
these people
now normally you could just say well
they're dumb that's why they're in tv in
the first place reading scripts that
somebody else wrote i mean it really is
like anchorman if you want to be totally
honest about it hair hats reading words
they don't understand that is true
that's actually what it is but in this
case it's more than ignorance it's more
than stupidity it's complicity in a
campaign
to fool the public
to make you believe that your personal
concerns like the fact you can't buy
food or drive anywhere or the police
won't come because they can't afford gas
those are not important
what's really important is some other
thing that you should be terrified of
russia it's putin it's queuing on it's
the white supremacists are going to get
you
and anyone who worries about gas prices
anyone who's concerned about how to feed
his or her family gets a lecture that
actually you're just selfish this is a
pandemic of the unvaccinated really
or whatever the talking point is here
was cnn last night watch
but i think for something like this to
happen to have an attack on the capitals
have an attack on our democracy to have
a president of the united states saying
um that he won the election when he
didn't i think that is more important
than anything if you don't have a
functioning democracy then it doesn't
matter if you have
a penny gas prices you don't have a
functioning democracy and people are
going to think well this is what does
this matter for gas prices or whatever
okay fine we'll get to the gas prices
that's always going to have what does
this mean for inflation fine we'll get
to that we talk about that all the time
what this means for our democracy is the
most important thing and that's what we
should be focusing on oh a civics lesson
from doug lamont mr lamont tell us about
democracy what is democracy just sum it
up for us if you would it's a term you
use a lot what is democracy well
democracy is the process by which
government represents voters and their
concerns voters vote on representatives
they go to washington and they carry
with them in their hearts the memory of
the people who put them there and their
concerns are first and foremost so what
are the first and foremost concerns of
american voters the people at the heart
of this democracy well
food and gas prices
but the people who are defending
democracy
look at those people and say shut up you
selfish rube
you really should care about january 6
because democracy
the overwhelming majority of americans
don't care about january 6th and that's
why they need to beat you in the face
with it again and again and again they
wouldn't be hysterical they wouldn't be
repetitive they wouldn't be patronizing
if you actually cared but you don't so
they have to lecture you like a child
so the midterms approaching this is the
body administration strategy
talk about something else shame you if
you don't think it's the most important
thing
so biden began talking hey this speech
was built as an address on inflation
but it didn't begin with inflation or
any honest
account of how we got here and how we're
going to get out of it no
it was about january 6th watch
before i begin i want to say a few words
very briefly about
the january 6 hearings that were
highlighted last night
the insurrection on january 6 one of the
darkest chapters in our nation's history
brutal assault on our democracy brutal
attack on law enforcement some losing
their lives
and we we heard about it last night
again but i know together and i mean
this we can unite and defend this nation
democrat and republican
allow no one
to place a dagger at the throat of our
democracy
i mean
the overstatement is so ridiculous
you look at everything that's going on
in the world we know what happened on
january 6 because no event in human
history has had more cameras trained on
it you can watch the video you can spend
the rest of your life watching the video
on the internet
why don't you go ahead and do that get
back to us does that look like a dagger
at the heart of democracy is that the
darkest chapter in american history it's
like insane that you even talk like that
it's queuing on really trump is bad
it's repulsive actually when you think
about it russia is threatening to
destroy new york city with nuclear
weapons so how are we doing on that
front well it turns out
we're sourcing a critical component in
our ammunition not just small arms but
nuclear weapons from china
so at a moment we're actually closer to
war than at any time in your lifetime at
any time since 1945 since the big war
ended we're closer right now than any
time since then
and what are we doing about this what's
the state department doing to fix the
crisis in eastern europe well they have
they just announced this they've hired a
global equity ambassador well that'll
fix it oh more equity
this is nuts it's like rearranging
bookshelves by title as your house burns
down this is a species of mental illness
everybody sees how fake this is nobody
is convinced by it it was just two years
ago live on television summer of 2020 a
mob of biden voters tried to storm the
white house remember this they torched a
church across the street they attacked
secret service officers a mob called for
the president united states to be
lynched he was taken to an underground
bunker for his safety
we don't like to be hysterical we kind
of downplayed it at the time probably
shouldn't have maybe we should was
as hysterical as joe biden this was
pearl harbor
but that had been lying so we didn't
this is what our country's capital
looked like at the
[Applause]
[Music]
man come time
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm
[Music]
you really sort of hate to get into the
war of well you think that's bad this
was worse look at our tape
but really it's just too much
stop lying to us stop telling us things
that we know for a fact are not true
because we watch them in real time
you didn't hear anything
about that
last night about similar riots destroyed
cities all over the united states you
didn't hear a single word none of that
was a dagger at the throat of our
democracy all of it happened in an
election year with the aim of
influencing the election
unmentioned you heard not one word about
the guy who just tried to assassinate a
supreme court justice at his home at the
urging of the senate majority leader
can't talk about any of this these
topics like the state of the us economy
are now off limits you have to pretend
that january 6 2021 remains the single
worst thing ever to happen to america
even though not one living person really
believes that and if you don't say so if
you don't confess the one true faith in
public
you'll be hurt it just happened to an
nfl coach called jack del rio he just
learned this lesson
a completely soviet moment we've got
more on that in just a minute but first
take a few steps back
so this is a perverse arrangement and
you got to wonder who benefits
the congress and the entirety of
corporate media bury the actual problems
facing the united states pretend like
they're not even happening
why are they doing this and who is
getting rich from it inflation doesn't
happen by accident it's the product of
choices the inflation we're now living
through was created on purpose the
united states government got to a place
where the debt was too big and the only
answer
was to inflate it away
if you are a major debt holder
the only way out for you is to make the
money less
valuable and so they did this on purpose
they want inflation to skyrocket of
course and continue to rise you're not
going to hear any of that from the
professional commentators on cable news
but you will hear it from people who
still have common sense like this got a
gas station the day watch this
the economic jolts is not felt equally
a new bank of america report found
household credit card spending for fuel
surged to 7.8 percent by the end of may
but a whopping 9.5
for families making under 50 000 they
call it inflation but somebody in
somebody's pocket are getting inflated
we're the ones hurting down here you
know the poor people
okay
so
inflation
almost certainly is hurting you in fact
a new analysis out today
showed that the average
family will pay
this year a full month in its total
income just in inflation a full month
who's it good for well if you've got
massive corporate debt
it's a really good deal
because you get to pay yesterday's
accounts yesterday's debts with today's
inflated dollars that money has lower
real value so you are getting a deal
it's a scam
they're doing this on purpose but you
could only pull that off if the people
you were hurting were completely
distracted so let's scream at them some
more about january 6 then they might not
notice
at this point we don't really have a
choice but to tolerate inflation that's
the truth the traditional way to attack
inflation is to raise interest rates but
inflation has gotten so high that it's
going to be pretty tough to do that u.s
debt to gdp now stands at nearly 125
percent that means for every point we
raise the interest rate we're going to
wind up paying even more in interest
charges on that debt if the fed tries to
raise interest rates anyway to the point
they might actually affect inflation
what will that do well that's let's say
you bumped at 11 points i mean which
you'd probably have to do to get
inflation under control jerome powell
who runs the fed has already said
there's no limit to how high interest
rates could go
at least one financial expert said six
percent interest rates could be coming
and maybe that's just a start on top of
the ones we've already seen now what
would that mean for you
well interest rates that high would
crush
americans with credit card debt
and that's most of the country in fact
it's the highest rate ever it would make
buying a house basically impossible it
would crash markets it would crush asset
prices are we going to do that that's
kind of our option
probably not
so record inflation is likely here to
stay if you wonder why they're talking
about january 6th in prime time that's
why
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight